hi I'm Henry at 5 years old and today
I'm having to chat could be to make my
dream dish hi Henry I'm Betsy and I'm
Katie I'm curious if you were a sea
monster what would you eat even eat very
fishy Coral Wow Henry is just throwing
out ideas left and right okay so for he
starts with sand this is some
pointillism going on here this is very
good so the sand is the appetizer
why doesn't this sea monster like to eat
the jellyfish because I was jelly in it
saying that jellyfish has jelly inside
of it I'm not sure if he means like jam
or if he means like gross like guts so
we got sand we got jellyfish what's next
well how much we ask so speak to me the
coral is confusing me because he's
saying it's coral but it's kind of
looking like eyes he tickly okay so she
monsters like tickly coral got it the
last thing he eats is shipwreck Oh
shipwreck secret edible
definitely not wait are you could not
actually make it yeah we're gonna try
try will he do it I'm I'm expecting you
to make it whoa pressure is on ladies
he has very high expectations I think so
I don't want to let him down do you
think we can make your dream dish yes oh
I love the confidence
let's get to work high five mm-hmm
[Music]
okay so here's my plan for the sand I'm
gonna make a classic streusel topping
that I'm gonna spread all over the plate
for the shipwreck I'm gonna make a thin
fudgy brownie and use pretzels for
paneling then I'll make green and blue
poured sugar to mimic the shape of coral
and finally for the jellyfish I'm gonna
make puff pastry tentacles a jelly
filled heart I'm gonna cover that with a
white chocolate dome and top that off
with some pink sprinkles I'll be making
an edible interactive jell-o aquarium
I'll start with an ocean of blue jello
thickened with sweetened condensed milk
for my coral I'll be making some rice
krispies treats wrapped in marshmallow
fondant for the shipwreck I'm gonna make
a peanut brittle which I'll then crack
into shards for the jellyfish I'm gonna
make a vanilla cupcake filled with
strawberry jelly I'll then use
strawberry frosting to top the cupcake
and create the tentacles and finally for
the sand I'm gonna top everything off
with some yellow sweetened Kettlecorn
and sprinkles I can only hope that I can
deliver how are you feeling Katie what
are you doing first I am making blue
jello I can't even remember the last
time I even ate jello this is Katie its
water but it's like Betsy you I think
I'd like a childlike spirit I like that
about you hey I am gonna be making some
brownies one of my favorite brownie
recipes I've just combined regular
granulated sugar and brown sugar
together and then I've got about a stick
and a half of butter cuz all brownies
have some butter and now I've just added
three eggs and a little vanilla extract
to this we're get it nice and smooth
here I'm gonna sift in my dry
ingredients all-purpose flour some cocoa
powder and some salt semi-sweet
chocolate chips cuz I love kind of a
gooey brownie and hopefully Henry does
too definitely team gooey for sure
usually I would put these in this much
smaller like square pan but because I
want things to be more like pieces of a
ship I'm doing a thinner browning
situation here okay so I'm gonna go bake
my brownies at 350 degrees I'm feeling
really good right now I'm getting the
brownies in lickety-split smooth sailing
except I forgot something very important
okay Betsy I forgot to put the pretzels
on this the one thing that's gonna make
this even like sort of resemble a ship
whoops is this looking like a boat to
you not like a bow well like the side of
a boat yes ship laughs they call what
shiplap where are you a pirate how do
you know that haha so to speed up the
jello setting process I'm gonna add in
some ice-cold water to the jello mixture
that we already have Wow very wild I am
adding in some sweetened condensed milk
- hopefully thicken up the jello this
way the elements will look like they're
actually floating in the ocean or are
submerged in the sea I like literally do
not test this before this looks crazy
it's like literally sinking to the
bottom of the bowl this could literally
fail we don't know Betsy is adding
condensed milk to her jello which I have
never seen before but I'm all for
experimenting I'm gonna add this into my
casserole dish
please don't spill and stain the nice
white so I'm gonna take my reserved
jello mixture add maybe one or two drops
of blue food coloring and then hopefully
incorporate it into the thickened jello
mixture to kind of create a fun wavy
swirly effect I hope it works alright
here it goes
[Music]
okay okay hey I don't know guys I think
it's looking cool it kind of looks like
a polluted ocean it doesn't look
polluted okay so now I'm gonna make some
streusel for the sand so basically I've
got some flour I have got some brown
sugar and I've got cinnamon going in
here and then I'm gonna put in some cold
butter that's been sliced so that it can
be crumbly not melted in one form I'm a
toast it at 350 will be all crumbly and
delicious yeah and my brownies oh my
brownies are looking good
i feel like i'm maanna I'm not a good
Drac a winning track I am moving on to
the shipwrecks I'm gonna create a nice
peanut butter brittle I'm gonna add in
some white corn syrup here a little bit
of water and a pinch of salt you're
basically making kind of a candy right
like yeah yeah you have to get the sugar
up to a high temperature the sugar in
this mixture has dissolved so now I'm
gonna add in my peanuts hope you like
peanuts Henry and now we wait I'm gonna
be making some coral mining sugar and a
little corn syrup and some water
together and I'll heat all of that up to
275 around like a hard crack I'm gonna
add some green dye and a little
flavoring and then I'm gonna pour it
over ice and we'll see if it works I
feel like I added the peanuts maybe he'd
be too soon they're starting to brown
pretty quickly they're gonna great all
right nice Tovar here
I appreciate you forever an optimist
this is my song hey let's make up theme
songs Betsy and I love to sing songs at
work yeah
[Music]
Katie and I have been talking about
tasty to musical for probably close to
two years like one song would be like
gotta get the bike shot gotta get that
bite shot
we're usually doing a little dance sing
a little tune I just dropped a bowl and
bubble what about the cheese oh the
cheese ball if you want to see it tasty
the musical come to my comment below so
our butter is melted and like the baking
soda give like a really cool effect so
it's super thick and we are now quickly
gonna dump this on to our greased baking
sheet whoo nice and light golden yeah
I'm up to the the hard crack temperature
right now I'm gonna take it off the heat
and I just got to get it over the ice
before it starts cooling down too much
otherwise it's not gonna drip all the
way through the ice and it's just gonna
clump up at the top this is one of my
showcase elements if I'm gonna win I
gotta get this right okay and then I'm
gonna do a little darker my other Bowl
we'll see is this even darker but I'm
like a little afraid that that's SATs
you long but we'll see if that didn't
like pour as much but I think these are
looking good I'm gonna pull one out when
the ice melts it'll be all on its own it
really looks like coral okay good he's
not looking amazing I think I'm getting
my sea legs so I really want the top of
the cupcake to kind of like overflow to
kind of give that right shape of the
jellyfish a jellyfish doesn't exactly
look like a cupcake
so I'm not really sure how I'm gonna
make a cupcake look like a jellyfish so
I have four extra cupcakes to fall back
on if I make a mistake I wanted to do
two colors and when I took the time to
do the darker green my sugar started to
cool too much so it didn't fall through
the ice so I'm gonna restart I think I
have enough time to do it just I can get
that really nice height to my pork sugar
what are you doing I am getting started
on my next step for my coral so I'll be
making some rice krispie treats but I'm
cover it in a green marshmallow fondant
I just have one bag of mini marshmallows
in this bowl we're gonna microwave this
on medium power until the marshmallows
are fully melted my sugar is ready I'm
gonna leave it on the heat so it doesn't
cool too fast and I'm using watermelon
and I'm gonna do a little bit more
extract this time all right here we go
it looks like jelly rancher I'm burning
sugar that's not crazy okay I'm excited
I like that color a lot I was like burnt
sugar we're getting closer
hey it's happening don't jiggle that
that's nothing okay stop jiggly I like
yes looks so good
definitely worth going back and doing it
again as I'm watching Katie pull her
coral out of the ice I'm thinking like I
might be in trouble
I put the marshmallows and four
tablespoons of softened butter we've got
five cups of powdered sugar get it we're
gonna make a little well in the center
this might get a little messy and now
we're gonna add in our melted
marshmallows right in the center there
here we go guys oh this is fun this is
what I want like ah Sh I'm just like so
happy I'm happy for you so next we're
gonna dye it green I'm gonna start off
with a one drop and now I'm gonna start
incorporating into the fondant I may
have to add more as we go one two three
four five drops food colors so here's
another pro tip add your food coloring
as you're melting your marshmallows not
after when you're actually making your
fondant basically just don't do what I
do I'm gonna be working on the tentacles
of my jellyfish
oh cool and I'm making a little heart to
go inside my jellyfish filled with
healthy is that morbid I know Henry
didn't ask for a heart but I do want
something to be revealed when he takes
off the white chocolate dome
maybe this heart will be the key
to winning his heart I cut some
raspberry jelly and I am gonna spread
that out on one half of this a pastry
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten boys last number hmm I am
twirling them so they get the nice
little red jam stripe and then I am kind
of like making them a little wavy like
they're in the ocean so what I'm doing
now is I'm cutting out a heart and then
a little heart inside the heart cuz
that's what I'm gonna fill with jelly
and some fresh fruit great I'm gonna go
bake this in the oven for about ten
minutes at 400 degrees I'm gonna start
making my favorite dessert ever
rice krispies treats I personally love
my rice krispies treats on more of the
OE gooey side so I always like to add
less rice krispies than what most
recipes will call for they're just so
easy to make you literally only need
three ingredients so these marshmallows
it's gotta melt what I may do next is
fill the cupcake with jelly I'm gonna
add a little jelly to this piping bag
here it's literally already coming out
the bottom oh no I really don't know how
this is gonna go
okay cute you did it yeah why do I have
losses why do I have balloons great
question I'm gonna try to make a white
chocolate dome for the jellyfish you are
ambitious today Katie I I have never
done this before ever I'm worried that
the balloons are gonna pop or when they
pop they're gonna crack the white
chocolate I'm not gonna make the white
chocolate thick enough many things can
go wrong here but if it works maybe
it'll put me over the top
do you want to blow up a balloon sure
Wow years a party hard to be a clown but
you work is that I was a clown in
college
Katie Chris clapping in college we don't
even talk about that I was a clown in
college but like an Italian mime clown
it was very professional so the balloons
are ready to rumble I've got some white
chocolate I'm gonna add a little bit of
coconut oil cuz that's gonna help it
melts and be nice and smooth my white
chocolate is just about ready I'm gonna
add my dye and now to give it a pink and
red vibe and I'm gonna do it like a
swirled like a swirly jelly I want to
make at least two domes just in case I'm
just I'm gonna test to see if it'll pop
oh god I don't know it's just so
stressful right now whoa
that's scary Katie I totally see a
jellyfish in there after you yes okay
thanks mom
okay I am so happy without these
balloons stayed together I'm gonna go
chill them for a minute I'm scared of
the Traveling it's done Betsy Betsy can
you grab the tablecloth yeah yeah yeah
under okay
okay I'm gonna leave oh he got out
without our deck just don't breathe I'm
gonna trough the heat and at my rice
krispies I just eyeballed that guys I'm
gonna reset my hands and start forming
some of this coral here from our rice
krispies the advantage of a gooey rice
krispies in this case is that it
actually gives me more control in
shaping the Rice Krispies coral so I'm
cutting some fondant around one of the
coral Krispies okay you think they're
ready I think they are what since I've
never done this before oh I didn't crack
I think they're ready Reese show is
gonna give me a heart attack I'm not
sure gonna pop it gonna pop it oh oh my
gosh it's working I can't believe it I'm
so excited I'm gonna do this at home I'm
gonna do this all the time I'm gonna eat
ice cream in it I'm gonna eat sketti in
it maybe I'm gonna make my little
prickly tickly it's whoever out of so my
fondant feel like if I layer these it
kind of gives like an effective seaweed
all right I'm gonna just set this the
fun in the side and move on to my sand
so I just have a little bit of sugar
here I'm gonna add in just a drop of
yellow food coloring oh that's was more
than a drop that was more than shocked
Katie's streusel sand looks like sand my
sand plan not gonna be very close to the
hakka I'm making some sweetened yellow
kettle corn and then kind of topping
that off with a really fun sprinkle
mixture so hopefully a little creativity
and some imagination will be in my
oh it prepped this is crazy
it looks good in a nice yellow on it so
your jellyfish is like the star of your
show oh yeah jellyfish oh my gosh real
creepy this might be the coolest thing
I've made on I draw you cook seeing
Katie's dish start to come together my
confidence is kind of my jello is ready
time to assemble oh my gosh I'm gonna
finish my assembly as well moment of
truth are my items going to float maybe
I'll do the jellyfish first oh my gosh
I'm nervous for you to set anything on
top of it it's floating and the coral is
floating people I'm gonna bring my
completed brittle over and break it to
create a shipwreck you want to help me
sure
no just like jagged edges and then we
can kind of go from there weird I don't
know all right all we have left is to
create our jellyfish so I'm piping the
strawberry frosting on top of the
cupcake it's kind of looking like a
typical frosted cupcake what a freaking
frosting your scene is so alive it's
swimming well I'm done I think I'm done
- are you ready to walk the plank yeah
find out of these guys are seaworthy
my dish doesn't look exactly the way I
envisioned it but I think it strongly
resembles Henry's drawing I love how my
dish jiggles they say don't play with
your food
but I think Henry's gonna have a good
time playing with this I really like how
the dish turned out I think that the
coral looks so magical and the dome is
really fun that reveal is gonna be
awesome
there's puff pastry there's jam there's
streusel I think that Henry is gonna
have a really fun time taking apart this
dish Henry thinks it's cool I think this
looks better in my joint that's yummy
he's loving Betsy's dish Oh
gooey slime did he just cover it slide
down boy hmm it looks like Henry is
having a ton of fun eating his way
through this dish and I'm having a ton
of fun watching him do it Henry is
eating Betsy's plate like it's a toy
he's playing with it like it's Legos and
he gets to eat them I am getting worried
mmm yummy
I like this tray my work here is done
Wow it looks cool huh but this is so
lien I don't know what that is he's
right the coral does not look like it's
dry but it tastes great
okay and I think this is off the purse
Oh what that's a jellyfish I do love an
r8
I do and I'm happy that he feels loved a
spider how new things disgust do you
know cuz pizzas
was it the heart tastes like couscous
you're welcome what is your favorite
thing while I'm eating right now
Henry is obsessed with Katie's poured
sugar quarrel maybe I don't got this he
seems to like both of them a lot it's
really anyone's game at this point but I
hope it goes my way how are you I'm okay
you're okay
did you eat a lot of food yeah so Henry
you have tried two dishes the jello
ocean and the coral lollies which one
did you like the best one here surprise
oh my gosh truly an honor Thank You
Henry
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]